and I watched linoleum
and I was just I was my jaw dropped I'm
like
you know he goes maybe this is why they
always say comedians are the best actors
dramatic actors because I watched a
trailer which I now have to see of being
frank which looks hilarious but like
linoleum
I don't even recognize you and it took
me forever to go is that is he playing
that guy too no he's got a different
voice he he looks completely different I
was baffled by it oh well thanks yes
well you know you know this is the
perception industry right
and so
I you know and I'm sure that like you
were
forever trying to like not be Lex Luthor
right so you're you know the perception
thing is there is uh so like look I like
stand-up comedy I mean I love stand-up
comedy I love comedy and all that but
like
for me it's about what's
creatively fulfilling and so
um the more complex a role usually in an
indie usually in a drama is more
fulfilling acting and so I'd rather do
that than you know I mean I'd have fun
on a uh working on a comedy you know but
it's not as fulfilling probably as
playing
uh you know a guy who believes in snake
healing you know I did this movie them
that follow that you know like that's
you know like there's kind of the the
minutia of dramatic roles that are
it's uh it's more fulfilling I think
yeah you know I mean comedy's fun but
like
uh and maybe because I get to do stand
up that I don't feel the need to kind of
um
go go into that thing but it's you know
so I'm perceived as a comedian and then
I've ever whenever I do a movie and then
there's a press afterwards it's it's
always like people don't realize that
I've been doing uh dramas for a while
because none of them are that successful
so it's like but it's all right it's you
know there's got to be a narrative to
everything yeah I think they do it's I
said to Ryan I said there's no dad I
could totally see you getting nominated
for an Oscar sometime I I just genuinely
not because I'm not blowing smoke it's
just because
I just don't when people see it it's
like you're you're just so different
which is great the juxtaposition of
seeing you doing comedy and being the
funny guy and very personal and then
playing this quirky character from a
little place in Ohio and so you know and
look linoleum
is screening right now at the Palm
Springs International Fest it was in
South by Southwest so when Awards Tony
Shalhoub the whole cast is great
um it's it's just what I was talking to
publicist again I was like you know it's
touching it's mysterious it's thought
provoking uh at the end it brought me to
tears for some reason because I don't
want to say anything but like the old
man with the you know I don't want to
give it away but like just the whole
thing and then putting it together I was
like did I get this right is this what I
this is what I my interpretation was and
she was like yeah that's that's right
and I came gave myself a pat on the back
but um it deals with issues of identity
and memory and achievement but deals
with hope as sad as it can be at times
and uh you know I just I really and I
watched it this morning dude and getting
me to watch anything yeah I'm
like so I was like I really urge people
to go see linoleum when it comes out in
selected theaters and whenever do you
have any idea when that's going to be
here right now we'll just post it